use a calculator to find log base e of
67 to the nearest thousand so just as a
reminder E is one of these crazy numbers
that shows up in nature and Finance and
all these things and it's approximately
equal to two point seven one and it just
keeps going on and on and on so you
could view log base E as 67 you might
say what does e mean e is just a number
just like pi is just a number so this is
really the same thing as saying log base
two point seven one and the actual
number so you'd have to write all the
digits that keep on going forever and
and never repeat six of 67 so what power
do I have to raise e to to get to 67 so
another way of saying that is if this is
equal to X you're saying e to the X is
equal to 67 we need to figure out what X
is now traditionally you will never see
someone write log base E even though E
is one of the most common basis to take
a logarithm of and so the reason why you
wouldn't see log base E written this way
is log base E is referred to as the
natural logarithm and I think that's
used because I shows up so many times in
nature so log base E of 67 another way
of saying that or seeing that and the
more typical way of seeing that is the
natural log the lot and I think that
this is Ln so I think it's maybe from
French or something log natural of 67 so
this is the same thing as log base e of
67 this is saying the exact same thing
to what power do I have to raise e to to
get 67 when you see this Ln it literally
means log base E now they let us use a
calculator and that's good because I
don't know off the top of my head what
power up to raise to point seven one so
on and so forth to what power have to
raise that to to get to 67 so we'll get
our calculator out so we get the ti-85
out and different calculators will have
different ways of doing it if you have a
graphing calculator like this you
literally can literally type in the
statement natural log of 67 and then
evaluate it so here this is the button
for Ln means natural log log natural
maybe Ln of 67 and then
press ENTER give you the answer if you
don't have a graphing calculator you
might have to press 67 or and then a
value and then press natural log to give
you the answer but a graphing calculator
can literally type it in the way that
you would write it out and then you
press Enter
so for point two zero four six nine and
we want to round to the nearest
thousandth so this is a thousands place
right here this for the digit after that
is five or larger to six so we're going
to round up so this is four point two
zero five so this is approximately equal
to four point two four point two zero
five and it actually makes a lot of
sense because we know that e is greater
than 2 and it is less than and it is
less than three and if you think about
what 2 to the fourth power two to the
fourth power gets you to 16 and 3 to the
fourth power gets you to get you to 81
67 is between 16 and 81 and E is between
2 and 3 so it at least it feels right
that's something that's like two point
seven one two the little over the fourth
power should get you to a number that's
pretty close to three to the fourth
power and actually that makes sense
because it's actually closer to three
two point seven one is closer to three
than it is to two so this feels right
that you take this to the fourth little
over the fourth power you get to 67